hey everybody dion robon here markets
reporter at the wall street journal this
is our uh special edition we are
unpacking today's pce inflation report
uh inflation has been the big theme in
markets over the past
man it seems like almost the past year
so it's been
really the number one topic that
investors have looked to the thing most
moving the markets
the thing that's most motivating and
moving the federal reserve which we all
know that's the big trade right there
what the fed does so we are looking into
and unpacking today's pce personal
consumption expenditures report
that just came out this morning at 8 30.
the news showing once again
pce inflation is at the highest rate in
40 years this time going back to 1981
um higher than well actually lower than
expected but still higher than the
previous month so inflation's still
picking up
but there's a big but when you talk
about that number it's getting higher
but all the components within the report
are telling us that this looks like we
may have peaked out here and we could be
going down moving towards lower
inflation in the future rather than
getting those month to month to month
increases in pce so i want to talk
through what the pc report is what it
said what we learned from it and what we
can expect based on what we've seen from
the market and what we've seen thus far
uh from investors and you know otherwise
the reports that we've seen so we're
going to get into all that talking all
about pce the personal consumption
expenditures report
right here on youtube so let's get into
it let's let's dive deep into the report
obviously the big takeaway like i said
highest number since 1981. pc inflation
hasn't been moving this fast since 1981
that's 41 years ago but
we saw if you look at the core numbers
and the number that takes out food and
energy prices which historically are
very volatile they move around a lot and
so to really see the core trend of where
inflation's moving the federal reserve
and economists like to look at that core
number and that number shows that
inflation actually slowed down from
february in march so inflation actually
slowing down on the core piece of of the
cp or the pce excuse me and starting to
maybe move lower now the big but to the
butt
is that while inflation does look like
it's slowing down it's not slowing down
at a super fast pace the month over
month number was 0.3 that was the same
as the previous month so we're
hitting that peak where inflation's not
picking up super fast that we're slowing
down particularly on the core number and
that's what economists really pay the
most attention to especially those
economists at the federal reserve
also some good news than the reports
personal spending was up 1.1 percent
that means that folks are going out
spending money they're buying things
they're they're continuing to not be
pushed out of the market by inflation
they're not saying oh my god things are
too expensive let me just pull back on
what i was doing stay home and not go
out we did see more spending and that
was well above expectations the butt to
the butt to the butt
um you know the the core income personal
income was only up about half a percent
well below the overall rise in inflation
and that's telling us again
consumers are still spending they've got
big savings gluts away put away at home
in their savings accounts so they can
spend but their incomes aren't going up
fast enough to keep up with the overall
pace at which prices are rising so we
saw that again in march that's not a
good sign because when you get prices
rising faster than incomes faster than
folks are making money that can lead to
stagflation and some of these
longer-term inflation things that can be
a bigger problem
when we look out at the market the the s
p 500 right now stocks across the board
are down and in the red
but we started out the day like i said
that report came out at 8 30 a.m market
opened up at 9 30 a.m and we just we we
went up higher for a little bit and then
right around that 10 p.m time you saw
the market really just kind of sell off
within stocks bond yields a little bit
higher today we are seeing some of what
folks in the bond market call
bare flattening which means the curve is
getting flatter the shorter data yields
are rising faster than the longer data
yields which means that yield curve is
flattening out going from this to kind
of this right here as investors price in
a faster pace of rate increases from the
federal reserve
uh we're going to dive all into that i
wanna i wanna take a step back and talk
about the big picture right so the
biggest question that we thought to have
answered with this report was
are
is the pace of overall inflation slowing
down or is it continuing to rise well
big picture the headline number it is
still rising and it's rising at the
fastest pace in 40 years but when you
take out volatile food and energy which
you know can jump significantly from
month to month or dive
when you strip that out and look at just
the core which is you know food which is
sorry it's not food
which is uh housing which is what people
are paying you know for goods that they
buy out in the stores for going out
dining things like that that core pace
is starting to slow down and moderate so
yes the pace of overall inflation is
still continuing to rise at the fastest
pace in 40 years but when you get inside
the report we are seeing that things are
slowing down again i want to just remind
you guys this is a live stream we are
talking about the pce inflation report
the fed's favored measure for inflation
it's what the federal reserve and all
those economists out there with their
phds look at when they are calculating
here's what inflation is looking like
even though that consumer price index
cpi is more popular among regular
everyday folks that's what most people
look at that's up there at eight and a
half percent for march the pce personal
consumption expenditures that's at only
six point six percent i'm gonna explain
to you the difference and what those two
mean a little bit later uh but right now
just wanna wanna get into the the other
big picture which is the federal reserve
right what what are they thinking about
this and this doesn't give us any more
information than what we had this kind
of confirms the information that we had
inflation was spiking higher it was
moving consistently higher at a very
past a very fast rate the fastest pace
in 40 years
and that looks like it continued um you
got you know right now one of the
reasons that a lot of economists say
that okay you know we think we've hit
this high and now we're going to come
down is because first of all 2021
inflation was during this period right
when you look at january february march
that was a slower period of inflation so
it's a lot easier to get up higher and
get those readings that are seven
percent higher eight percent higher as
we move into
april may june and obviously we're
already in april but we get the report
for april in may the report obviously
comes the month after the actual thing
that's being measured so once we get
that april may june july all those
numbers were when the comparisons got a
little bit harder because inflation was
rising at a faster pace last year
and it was coming off of a higher or a
lower base for 2020. so those numbers
are going to keep rising economists
expect but the pace at which we're
rising is going to slow down just
because let's say for example inflation
was at a level of 10 uh in 2021 well now
it's at a level of 12. and so 12 is
still high but it's not that much higher
than 10 whereas
previously we were looking at inflation
a level of 10 compared to a level of 5
in 2020 so that's double the pace in
2021 but then you move into 2022 and
it's only 20 percent more
that's what's going to happen and start
to happen over the next few months we're
going to get these tougher comparisons
where inflation was higher a year ago so
what it looks like compared to a year
ago isn't going to be as fast but still
a very fast pace the other thing that
we're seeing is a strong dollar
that's what we've seen consistently in
the markets uh for about the past four
months really most of this year is a
strong dollar and we're looking at some
economists are calling for pair um
parity with the euro as in dollar and
euro worth one to one so those of you
who've been thinking about a european
vacation
now might be a pretty good time things
are going to be getting a little bit
cheaper for you
um the big picture question is is
inflation going to come down and
economists say based on what we've seen
in this pc report based on what we saw
in the march cpi report it looks like
that's what's happening but
that might not be the case there are
reasons that we could see inflation
continue to rise higher the big one has
been consumer expectations of inflation
we saw the new york fed's survey of
consumers show us that uh consumers
expect 6.6 percent inflation that's the
highest since surveys since they began
taking that survey in 2013
consumers are saying we expect inflation
to be well above what the fed says they
expect inflation to be we expect it to
be
well above what it normally is and
continue to grow to rise higher that
despite everything the fed has said that
they're on the case that they're going
to be raising rates that they've got
what it takes to choke off inflation and
interest the market also seeing that and
expecting that inflation is going to be
higher for a longer period of time when
you look at the 10-year break-even rate
when you look at five-year five-year
forwards and break even forwards those
are showing that investors expect
inflation to be at least three percent
over the next 10 years
when you look at that 10-year break-even
inflation rate that's the highest that
that rate has been since they started
tracking it now they only started
tracking it in the early 2000s but
that's still the highest that rate has
ever been so the market making very
clear it expects inflation to stick
around for longer that may mean that yes
we've peaked here with this pce report
and things are going to start coming
down but the market is saying even over
the next the next decade we don't expect
the fed to be able to get in to be able
to get inflation down to its two percent
target that's what we're seeing in the
market that's what we're seeing from
consumers uh that's gonna have to change
and the fed's gonna have to be a big
part of changing that with raising rates
and with their forward guidance
a big factor in that has been the war in
ukraine
as this war has lasted a lot longer than
i think a lot of folks expected that it
would and has just continued on with no
end in sight well the drag on on prices
coming down for oil and wheat that's
going to continue as well so oil prices
spiked up over a hundred thirty dollars
a barrel we've seen them come down from
that but they're still holding in at
that level above uh not above 100 per
barrel that is a very important level
and as long as oil prices stay above
that you're going to see prices at the
pump stay elevated and that makes
everything more expensive everything
gets delivered on trucks
from ships airplanes those things all
rely on some form of oil and as long as
the price of oil stays high the cost of
all of that gets factored in to all of
those different things anything that you
need to have shipped to a grocery store
to your house to the the store the
neighborhood store where you shop that
gets more expensive because transport
costs are more expensive you've also got
coveted lockdowns in china which have
further embroiled some of these supply
chain issues as well as shut down
manufacturing if you're locked in your
house because you can't go outside
because this covett outbreak well you
can't do your manufacturing job you
can't produce those products that we
need here in the u.s and the chinese
government says that's too bad we're
locking people down because we want to
stop this covet outbreak by any means
necessary so that is further slowing
down supply chains and manufacturing
across the world because china is such a
big hub for all that that makes prices
higher if i know that you can't get your
stuff produced over here at that cheap
rate i'm going to raise my price and say
hey you know what i got a lot of
business coming in here a lot of folks
looking for a new supplier my prices
just went up
and because it's going to cost me more
to do business that's just keeping
prices elevated and moving things higher
so again we've seen the war in ukraine
that that covid uh outbreak in china as
well as housing prices rising at double
digits continued here in the u.s we got
a bunch of housing data last week and
all of it pretty routinely confirmed
homes still rising 15 to 20
30 in some parts of the country that's
home prices as well as mortgage rates at
five percent and over five percent at
this point um
and that's that's just keeping prices
elevated so you've got a number of these
different things that are weighing on
the outlook for this price pressure to
cease again want to remind you guys we
are here doing this big pce breakout
usually you know we summarize the whole
week and i talked to you about that but
today it's all about pce inflation it's
all about what's going on in the
inflation in the world of inflation
prices and how that's going to impact
the fed we've been talking about
how the expectation is for economists or
the expectations from economists that we
have hit the peak here and we're going
to start coming down but the market
showing that we expect to come down but
at a much slower pace than expected um
the other big piece of data we got
because a lot of pce data you could have
pulled out of the gdp report that came
out that came out yesterday today we got
the employment cost index and that was
at the highest pace in history a record
high and that's concerning for
economists because wage inflation is
stickier as in it's harder to get rid of
or harder to remove than other kinds of
inflation once consumers start to or
once workers start to get used to
getting raises at a certain level
they're not going to want to go back to
that previous level i mean think about
at your job if you get a five percent
increase this year you're not gonna want
a three percent increase next year right
you're gonna want a five or a six
percent price uh increase on your uh on
your pay
because you say hey i didn't do a worse
job this year why should my bonus or why
should my raise be lower than it was
last year
on the same token
if you took a job last year and
someone's trying to lure you away well
you're going to need more money to take
that new job after you just got more
money from the previous job that you
took so again all these things are a big
part of the report that we got today
that employment cost index that might be
the piece of data that's really most
concerning to the fed and i think the
thing that most people are going to be
talking about as you talk about
takeaways from this pce report
um
i want to just really quickly explain
one thing and that's how inflation is
measured you know you get these acronyms
pce cpi a lot of folks are like all
right what is that inflation yeah um pce
and cpi are measured differently one of
the big things is that within pce it
accounts for substitutes so if i've been
buying filet mignon every month for the
past 12 months and now the price of
filet mignon has reached this level and
i say hey you know what i'm going to buy
ground beef in the cpi that's all the
same you bought beef
uh in pce it accounts for the difference
between that filet mignon and that
ground beef and it says okay consumers
switch from filet mignon to ground beef
that means inflation's not moving at as
fast a pace as it was so
that's something that's a reason to keep
an eye on this pce report that we got
today
because it does break out inflation a
little differently inflation is all just
a matter of how much prices are rising
for housing food
gas all the things that you buy consumer
products when you go to the store how
much does that cost so the other big
piece this is fed expectations like i
said that employment cost index number
that we got today could worry the fed
and that could be something that a lot
of people are saying hey look over here
this weight this inflation may be
stickier you guys got to go at a faster
pace markets already pricing in a 50
basis point increase
for this month that's twice as fast as
what the fed normally hikes rates at and
expecting a 75 basis point increase in
june three times as fast after we got
this report today
expectations for fed increases went up
across the board so obviously this is
telling the fed there's more work to do
it needs to be done quickly and you guys
better get on it
but that's gonna that's gonna do it i
think we've covered everything that we
came to talk about in this pce inflation
report today i want to thank you guys
for tuning in and being with us here on
market takes i am dion robon market
supporter for the wall street journal uh
and we're gonna do this again on monday
we will be right here uh talking to you
guys about what to expect for the week
ahead and what you know kind of breaking
down what happened last week so join us
again next week on monday when we do
this uh the live stream again i want to
thank you guys for tuning in i have been
dianne bowen i appreciate you guys i'll
see you on monday